effectivement incroyable que ce qui
s'est passé hier que ce soit à new york
ou à washington
les premières images qui nous
parvenaient et hier après-midi était
impensable tout le monde pense et
regarder un film de fiction mauvais film
malheureusement c'était bel et bien la
réalité
nous allons maintenant revenir sur la
catastrophe
elle-même les différents attentats qui
sont survenus donc hier en début d'après
midi au dessus de new york au dessus de
washington avec toute une série de films
qui ont été tournés soit par les
télévisions soit par des cinéastes
amateurs et nous allons voir cette
catastrophe filmée
si je puis dire sous tous les ans le
film de la catastrophe
olivier carf il était 8 heures 56 à new
york
[Applaudissements]
un boeing vient de percuter le world
trade center tout le sommet de la tour
nord est en feu dévastée presque 15
heures à paris
9h du matin là bas c'est l'heure où
l'amérique démarre sa journée près de
cinquante mille personnes travaillent
dans ses tours jumelles des milliers
d'entre elles sont déjà dans les bureaux
attentats accidents dans ces minutes là
peu importe déjà des désespérés préfère
sauter dans le vide
la mairie va vivre son pire cauchemar en
direct 9h14
un deuxième avion de ligne et ventre la
tour sud
des dizaines de caméras sont déjà
braqués sur le world trade center la
scène passe et repasse sur les écrans du
monde entier
sur ces images on voit nettement le
deuxième boeing amorcé un virage pour
taper en plein milieu le building
quatre cents mètres plus bas au sol la
panique manhattan new york les états
unis chacun a compris il n'y a plus de
civils il n'y a plus de pompiers plus
policier il y a juste des milliers de
gens qui fuient l'horaire
mais les terroristes n'ont prévu de
laisser avec une demi-heure de répit aux
américains
yes
[Musique]
9h43 à washington un troisième avion
vient de s'écraser comme un missile sur
le pentagone
le temple la de la défense américaine
réputée invincible inviolable et
pourtant incendiée sous les décombres
toujours pas éteint l'heure actuelle des
centaines de morts
moins d'une demi heure plus tard un
quatrième avion s'écrase à pittsburgh
dans un bois à new york
le cauchemar n'est pas fini coup sur
coup les deux tours géantes du world
trade center s'effondrent
[Musique]
quelques heures plus tard un troisième
bâtiment cède manhattan s'enfonce dans
l'épaisse fumée dans une longue une très
longue nuit